my critique have had nothing to do with
her skin color and everything to do with
the fact she was telling a bunch of
Whoppers about the royal family and
causing them enormous damage how do we
get here Pierce because you mentioned
the Meghan Markle thing as well and it's
just like everything is racist now and
that's not to say that there aren't
racist people I am someone who's a first
generation immigrant I know there are
racist people in this country but I
don't remember a time when you know
office air conditioning was sexist and
this was Ray and ever ever it's
ridiculous how did this happen well the
most ridiculous example I can give you
wasn't actually me although I was
accused of being racist for disbelieving
Meghan markers truth which was a lie
which seemed to be Preposterous and
obviously my critique have heard nothing
to do with her skin color and everything
to do with the fact she was telling a
bunch of Whoppers about the royal family
and causing them enormous damage
um but the worst thing was Sharon
Osborne who was at the time co-hosting a
show called The Talk on CBS happy for 10
years very successful
um and I'd been on the talk many times
and she tweeted that I was entitled to
my opinion she didn't say she agreed
with him
that I was entitled to my opinion
and she was then set up on her show so
Cheryl Underwood who was one of the
black hosts of of the talk basically
played the race card and the incredibly
unpleasant manner deliberately to to try
and gotcha Sharon and basically made out
that she accused her of of supporting
somebody who'd said racist things so
Sharon kept saying what are you talking
about what did he say it was racist
and she couldn't answer it what did he
say there was racist he said racist
things and eventually we may not have
said racist things but you know he's
thinking you know in other words if I
didn't believe Meghan Markle who's from
a biracial couple you know white father
black mother if I didn't believe her it
had to be because I was racist
and it was an extraordinary thing Sharon
then lost her job over this because she
reacted so angrily to the suggestion
that I was a racist and therefore she
was supporting a racist none of that was
true and so to your point that's where
we are how did that happen how did we
get here in your opinion because you
would have seen this in your lifetime
I've seen that in my life identity
identity politics is the biggest problem
mixed with a society that now values and
celebrates victimhood
and weakness and losing over
previous generations who valued higher
strength winning resilience and all
those things that's what's happened so
you now see a ridiculous situation with
the gymnast Simone biles uh who in the
Olympics pulls out of the team
competition and she's obviously the Star
talent for the Americans and the
Russians end up winning it because she's
you know having anxiety issues makes a
dramatic recovery three days later to
take part in the individual comes third
and she normally wins all the goals
comes third and really it's because
she's just slightly lost her power she's
just not as good as she was that's the
real problem and she knew it she tumbled
a couple of times in the team
competition and it freaked her out that
she isn't as good as she used to be in
my opinion but she turned the whole
thing into a mental health this was all
about mental health all about her brave
anxiety you know facing down her brave
issues uh like anzard and so on and
everyone celebrated her cover of every
magazine becoming third and for bottling
it in the team
competition and letting a teammates down
so they lost and then recovering in time
to take part in our own thing and I've
learned to notice I went we've all got
nuts how can she be celebrated more for
losing and coming third and falling over
and letting down her teammates than she
did when she won all the goals and it's
funny Michael Johnson the brilliant you
know 200 and 400 meter Runner he pipes
up on Twitter at me how's it going me
for suggesting that winning bronze is
not somehow the greatest thing of all
time if it's so great how come your
Twitter name is MJ gold in your Twitter
bio all you mention are your gold medals
because of course he doesn't celebrate
Lucy that's why he's Michael Johnson the
Usain Bolt as a bronze medal dangling on
his toilet wall of course he doesn't
right so we've moved away now from
what I think is important in life which
is that you understand that the more you
work the harder you put in the more you
get back and actually winning's a good
thing in life in all aspects of life
whether it's relationships or you know
work or
friendships whatever it is or sport
anything
winning is not a bad thing it's a good
thing competition is a good thing you
know being able to lose and get back up
and think that sucked I don't want that
to happen again you know Alex Ferguson
at Manchester United used to say to his
players when they lost a big a big title
race
don't ever forget how you're feeling
right now and don't feel that again
you didn't go well don't lie to your
loss you're lost to Arsenal let's all go
party it's party time let's celebrate
losing and being a bunch of losers
that's not how he got to be the most
successful coach in history